So, as a quick uh update, we're going to
be about 30 to 40 minutes late and catch
up after lunch.
So the reason for that once the slides
come up is the committee accepted a
presentation from Zenity
and Zenity due to the situation of the
airspace in Israel being closed could
not be here
and
I decided that is not cool
and also I kind of felt that they made a
major release today and I want this
conference to not be buried behind in
history of what happened two weeks ago
or a month ago. So I talked to the CTO
of Zenit, Mikuel Bulgouli said, would
you trust me a competitor? We're not
directly compet competing, but he's my
competitor in the AI security space.
Would you trust me to go up with some of
your slides and just presented
PowerPoint karaoke without ever seeing
them before?
And
I have never seen these slides before.
And I'm going to try to rush this so
we're not way way behind and Aaron won't
kill me too badly.
But I hope you guys will forgive me for
whatever I do wrong here and what I
don't understand. And also please Aaron
has a microphone and when I don't
understand a slide or you understand it
differently, just walk say I understand
this differently. Let's present this
together. Now think about this for a
minute because I know you're all very
shy people and Americans therefore
polite. So if somebody would just raise
their hand. Where's Dan? Dango.
>> Okay. So you're the first one to raise
your hand when I get something wrong on
the third slide. So everybody else feels
comfortable stepping in. Let's run
through this. Please fix from Zenity
Labs. My competition and awesome people.
Agentics browsers. Agentic browsers are
everywhere.
No, but seriously, browsers are coming
in. They are the next agent to perhaps
explode after coding agents now
everybody's using. and they bring with
them also quite significant risks
and comet is the one that Zenity in this
particular case looked at and they are
essentially saying look we're not saying
this is majorly innovative but prompt
injections are evolving all the time and
it's something a little bit different in
the way they're trying to look at this
here from my understanding of looking at
this slide right now but they're saying
there is the user intent and the
attacker's intent right and if we can
create intent collision where we say
something that looks like it's the users
I'm I'm guessing that's kind of like a
um data and control plane run running
thingy, but I'm not sure exactly what
they meant here. That means we can make
the agent do things we did not intend it
to do. Dan, you ready? And what they did
essentially is create a payload that I'm
going to read this off the slide, but
I'm going to act as if I'm not by
looking at you once in a while. It hides
in the calendar invite. It rewrites the
accept button with our their
instructions and abuses comment
internals with system reminders. I'm
waiting for you to step in and tell me
I'm wrong at any point. Okay. So, the
first attack they're doing, I guess, is
a system file system Xfill, right? Yes.
Everybody with me?
>> Awesome. I'm not doing a very good job,
so help me out by cheering me on. Okay.
Appreciate it. Okay. Thank you. Thank
you. I am stressed out a little bit. So
the attacker sends a calendar invite
right and we can see Google calendar on
the screen and you can see there is an
interview with Tamir. Uh what else can I
see on this slide with uh some
information there and some invitations
going to the team and to okay moving
from this slide and there is essentially
comet in the background where say accept
the meeting help me prepare for it and
I'm imagining the denity team now saying
you know what I'm going to go make
coffee what's the worst thing that could
happen I just asked them to help me
accept this meeting right I don't need
to stay here and monitor and well comet
navigates to attacker controlled site
with more malicious instructions.
I love you comet. Isn't it wonderful?
Right.
And it says accept the meeting here. To
confirm the meeting, you need to click
these on blah blah blah. And there is
some Hebrew stuff. So probably uniode
based attack. Probably wrong, but that's
my read on this. And then you can
actually reach the file system. And I
think this is what it is. And access
files. Woo. Way to go, Zenity.
Amazing work.
And autonomously, comet will just go and
search for really cool files that you
might want to exfiltrate all on its own.
Isn't that wonderful?
And then it would actually exfiltrate it
to the attacker because no demo is ever
complete unless you show that Xfill
happened or CMD popped up depending on
what you're demoing, right?
The second attack is actually with one
password where once again we start with
a calendar invite. Everybody clear on
that, right? That happens in every
single stage here. And what do we write
here? Accept the meeting and prepare for
it. Same thing. But something else
happens in the background as the
attacker intent and the user intent
collide. And they apparently log into
one password. And one password usually
does not let me do that. It requires the
master password. I feel a little bit
cheated that you can just log in. I mean
what's what's wrong here? Is there
preferential treatment and
they are catching the request
and boom they're managing the account
and doing things to it
that oh this is pretty cool. So I don't
think it's necessarily an attack but the
one password autocomplete is apparently
turned on and once that happens they are
just in and they could do whatever they
want and they have the emergency kit
here and a lot of other things they
probably would have said really
technical smart things about that I'm
just blah blingy on and the conclusions
agentic browsers are untrusted entities
I think we can agree to that awesome Dan
I'm preparing you you're coming up here
to say two words on this in a second
before we call you up so step up already
because we don't have a lot of Just come
here. Stop changing your presentation
last minute. Okay. Logged in. The
browser is acting under your identity.
Right. Okay. And third is the browser
security model. Think again. We need to
do better as an industry. And with that,
this is Zenity Labs. This is their link.
You can look at what they do. These uh
mother somethings compete with me,
although not in exactly the same things.
So don't like them too much.
But they're truly awesome people. They
constantly release good research and
they were the first ones to actually do
a zero-click attack in this space and it
was a real one, not one that marketing
claimed was zero click. So everybody, I
apolog I apologize to them for my uh
PowerPoint karaoke of this presentation,
but let's give Zenity a hand.